the steelers had not been impressive in
their first four games of the season
even though they won all of them first
time since 1979 they started 4-0
yesterday though my goodness they
unleashed everything on the cleveland
browns and that defense has been awesome
first team since the 1985 giants to have
three sacks and an interception in each
of the first five games this season
and uh the thing cam hayward told me
after the game they just they knew you
got to get off the bus and stop the run
against the browns and if you do that
you'll be able to shut everything else
down and then uh you know they they they
created an avalanche effect by sensing
that frustration and just you know and
just they they knew
here it comes we can sense that the
browns are not happy with the way things
are going this wasn't as easy as it was
supposed to be they were supposed to be
better than they've been in past years
the steelers are supposed to be beatable
this year and it just fell right into
the steelers hands and you know i said
last week if i'm going to be wrong on
this one i'd rather be wrong that way
because i just had a feeling the browns
were going to get it together and
they just you know yeah we're
we're reminded that the steelers are the
steelers and the browns are the browns
and uh
chris
you know i don't want to take anything
away from what the steelers did but
baker mayfield i don't think he should
have even played i i he never looked
like himself now some of that had may
have had something to do with the
steelers but when you've got this chest
injury you're talking about how you just
sleep on your side instead of your back
yeah you're in pain and discomfort all
week right
should you really be playing the game or
jay glazer said he's going to start but
they don't know if he's going to finish
and he ultimately didn't finish i just
feel like they should have gotten him
off the field sooner maybe maybe they
should have just gone with case keenum
from the get-go well i mean it's
certainly easy to ask that now and i
mean i understand what you're asking i
mean he he's obviously banged up we know
that and then you're playing the
pittsburgh steelers and that great
defense but it's the kind of match up
that i guess like a guy like baker
mayfield there's no way he's missing
he's worked too hard these few years to
be in some of these games finally to go
whoa it's a meaningful you know brown
steelers game i'm not missing out on
this you know could i understand it
maybe at 17 nothing maybe where they
went okay he's not himself here let's
make a move now let's not get him killed
because he was taking some shots and
things like that i could have understood
that i would have had no problem with
that but you know the bottom line is
the steelers like you said made a
statement yesterday it was by far their
most complete football game and we saw
it all stop the run
turnovers hitting the quarterback and
then i think the other thing that's
really encouraging is they ran the
football and if pittsburgh can run the
football a little bit that's why some of
those wins we've talked about that are
not that impressive they can't close
teams out that way but they seem like
they're kind of getting it going another
week of we see chase claypool kind of
infused in the offense and make some
splash plays
uh i i i mean i i
i think they're one of the more complete
teams in football and i think yesterday
was the first time the defense played a
full four quarter dominant game like we
expect them to with the talent they have
on their roster
and here's the best evidence of it too
if you would tell me the steelers beat
the browns 38 to seven i would assume
ben roethlisberger had 350 passing yards
yeah 162. yeah right so i mean it was
james connor getting over 100 yards
rushing three rushing touchdowns
including chase claypool on that jet
sweep that i think it's just going to
become the standard part of the offense
because it works right it works keep
doing it it works put it on film there
there it's on film oh and we're gonna
we're gonna use the same format so what
stop it good luck yeah i mean that's the
you know coaches get so caught up and
coach dungey mentioned this last night
he likes it when teams will keep using
plays that work yes who cares if it's a
look that they've seen before who cares
if they see it coming if you can't stop
it it doesn't matter no it does not
you're right and a lot of times it's
good to wear those things out too to
where we talk about it forces teams to
then do something to stop it and that's
when you have the fake or something off
it or a tree you know a tree of plays
off of it that screw over the defense
from over playing their hand but i think
they have found that little aspect in
claypool as the new go-to guy to where
it is gonna force defense is like oh we
break the huddle where's 11 at where's
claypool oh okay hey let's make our
calls he's over there this time hey
check this we're doubling
i think he is going to become one of
those guys that defenses are very aware
of because he is the most dangerous guy
on that offense and hey pittsburgh you
know big ben's playing smart football
he's taking care of the ball
they didn't let miles garrett and the
defensive line ruin the game i felt like
they were very cognizant of not like
getting into a drop back we're gonna
throw it all over the place and let
sheldon richardson and miles garrett get
strip sack fumbles and put us in a tough
situation um ultimately though you know
the steelers with the pick six to start
the game right great that's steelers
football great disguise minka
fitzpatrick touchdown
the pressures everything like that but
the stopping the run game i mean we
talked about that with cleveland almost
every week of the year so far and there
was nothing i mean nothing there to be
had so those steeler that steelers front
seven was up for the challenge and i
think again it shows you a little with
cleveland and baker mayfield
you know it's a big question about them
when they can't run the ball how good
are they on offense right i mean at
least that's that's a question for me
because i don't think you can just trust
baker mayfield at this point right now
either just drop him back 45 times a
game and do that he's going to make some
mistakes and this is just not the style
of football they wanted to play
yesterday
with nick chubb still out kareem hunt
had four yards on 13 carries 3.1 yard
per carry average and no rushing
attempts for odell beckham jr a guy that
kevin stefanski stumbled onto as
as a supplement once nick chubb got
injured and he was great against the
dallas cowboys and he had that great
game and you know here's the problem
with otto beckham because we saw images
of him yesterday
slipping back into the
odell when things aren't going well
because
if they're winning
he's fine with not being involved yeah
or if they're losing and he's heavily
involved he's fine with that right where
the venn diagram implodes on a team yeah
he can't take both yeah because he
genuinely believes
if he was more involved they wouldn't be
losing agreed and and so you get both
halves come together and that's when
odell beckham jr slips into that guy
that you think maybe maybe he should be
traded maybe he is more trouble than
he's worth maybe it is
a a factor on the team
that isn't conducive to where they're
trying to go and and i've gone back and
forth now twice after week one it's like
well they got to trade this guy then
it's like hey four straight wins oh hey
this is working
yesterday when i saw those
old familiar images of the demeanor yeah
and just the whole you know it's like uh
you know is is he really
is he really a benefit because there's
going to be a game
in crunch time late in the season or in
the postseason
when it's not going their way and
instead of sulking and getting
frustrated you need somebody who's going
to say let's go out and change the
narrative yeah let's not go pout because
it's not going our way let's go make it
go our way right well i i hear you he
did slip into some old ways there a
little yesterday i still think it's
better than whatever we've seen before
like i do think there was some growth
immaturity there yeah i mean first off
he was less pouty he was less he was
well he was i mean listen he had his
moments of theatrics and things like
that too
but i think also we're gonna keep it
real too
he had a moment of like he was talking
to the offense and like trying to lead
them and you know you could tell he
wasn't yelling them he's like hey we got
to pick this crap up let's do this let's
do that this is what we've been doing
blah blah blah to where that was you
know that to me showed a little maturity
to where like oh he's being a leader
here he wasn't trying to like you know
what the hell are we doing why am i not
getting the ball now he had some other
body language moments and some actions
where yes i do think that but i don't
think it's to a distraction point yet or
anything like that the last two weeks he
has been very good for their team like
you said la yesterday i was shocked like
you early on they never got him the ball
or got him going
and stefanski told me i challenged
myself to get him involved early more
often and he was kind of decoy-ish
against the cult he was i don't know
what the goal was yesterday and here's
the thing too i think he gets very
conflicted in the moments where things
aren't going their way and it's
bothering him and he doesn't sense that
it's bothering the people around him and
that's where he gets and it's i just
want to win right in in new york when
you're dealing with eli manning as your
quarterback who's just kind of like well
you know and it works i mean he's got
two super bowl trophies from
you know but
when it when it's a bad day you want
somebody to get pissed off and start
calling people out like tom brady would
i think that's why there's always been
that magnet yeah that's tried to draw
tom brady and odell beckham jr together
because i think beckham's got that same
passion right he just doesn't know what
to do with it when he feels like no one
else has it i think that's very fair i i
really do i that's the way i kind of
always have read it as well it's not
it's not about a guy who wants to be
mean or a jerk or anything like that he
wants to get the ball because he thinks
he's awesome yes and he thinks he can
help the team that way and yes he does
do that as well and he lets the emotions
maybe get the best of him at times but
yesterday hey even though he teetered
close to the line there i didn't think
he crossed over and you know like i said
that one moment i saw leadership and
then i think the other things you can
look at too just like the clips we
showed on football night in america him
sitting on the bench next to baker you
know i'd be more worried about when it's
a game like that and baker's on the
bench and you see odell beckham jr on
the other side of the the sideline
that's when i would go oh i don't know
there might be an issue there now but
they're still there they're still
believing in what they do and we'll see
they're a young
still figuring out not battle tested
football team yet that's
you know slowly breaking down barriers
but they weren't ready for steel or
football that was hitting on all
cylinders like it was yesterday and
that's why
i mean crap i don't know i'm i'm
interested to see where you put the
steelers in your power rankings this
week
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports